oh hello how these touches real and i
just drew them on one day and um
they never went away so i just kind of
let them uh
let them just hang out my arm it's one
day maybe they might come off
i'm not sure
[Music]
hi i'm lil hoddy and today i'm doing the
wired auto complete interview
[Music]
this one says where was lohati born i
was born
in oakland california which is
in the the bay area so i guess i'm a
barrier baby
where does lahadi live i live
in encino california which is like
close to the beach i guess right i don't
even know
where does little huddy get his clothes
i actually shop a lot on
grail it's a shopping app and i buy 90
of my clothes from there or
i go to the flea markets on the weekends
and i kind of uh
get little things there where's the how
do you get his jewelry
i think i should have saved the flea
market because i get all my joy at the
flea market
online i guess too i like little places
but
no one place in specific other than uh
the flea market
where to watch the little hottie movie
you can watch downfalls high on
youtube and facebook actually i play
phoenix in downfalls high which is like
a young mgk in his uh
movie music video kind of a crossover to
make his album like have a story behind
it and then i'm playing
him in the story so go check it out
what little huddy i know this is gonna
be like this is gonna be good
hello huddy it what is lohati real name
my real name is cole chase hudson i was
given a choice between
going by cole and chase when i was like
four years old and
of course the name chase sounds more
appealing to a four-year-old
it also is my dad's first name my dad's
first name is
cole he's cool ellis hudson and so we
also didn't want to mix that up
so i don't know why they named me cole
but i always thought chase is cooler and
i still do so
so i'm chase what does little honey mean
this is a good question
my last name is hudson my great grandpa
would always call
my dad huddy that's something that my uh
my dad's always
liked as a nickname and has called me
he's always called me little huddy
because my dad was huddy so i've had
this nickname my whole life so it's not
something that i came up with because
of the rappers i promise why is lahari
zodiac i am a taurus
i know like a few things i'm like good
in relationships
and i'm uh stubborn and that's a fact
what is lottie's fandom called i've
called them
honey gang for a while i thought that
was cool and that's always like kind of
stuck with me i never really had like a
meaning behind it but
i've always uh called the money gang so
that's kind of cool to me
what does how do you eat in a day
this is gonna be so sad in the mornings
i'll eat cereal
cocoa pebbles like strawberry k those
are fire and then i eat
like what are they from like starbucks
they have a good ones like like little
sandwiches they're so good
or like a waffle and then for lunch
it's something between in and out and
taco bell it's one of the other it's
always the one or the other
and then for dinner i'll probably i'll
like either like go out or
have like pasta i cannot cook
to save my life but i can cook mac and
cheese if i have to
isla hadi there's a little hottie in the
high pass
yes i am i am a in the hive house
actually me and uh thomas uh co-founded
it
back in um 2019 i think
2019 yeah is oh my god i'm gonna rip
all of these is somebody australian
i'm not i'm not australian i'm actually
i'm scottish
and i'm uh irish and a little bit
like french i think yeah the next one
is isla okay you know
we have those days but we're uh we're
staying strong
my advice to you is to stay strong
because
this pandemic is temporary and is gonna
be something that
we kind of remember for the rest of our
lives so uh
make the best use of it because it's not
going to be normal life forever
this little hoodie going on tour as of
i don't think so but i think touring's
going to be back on in
2022 or late this year but i don't
really know
what's going on nobody really knows at
this point so you never know
this next one is his little hoodie
rich i would not say i'm rich i mean i'm
renting a house it's not like i own six
properties or anything like
i'm but i'm doing good for myself i'd
say i got a nice car
i'm rich and friendship i'm rich in love
all right yeah this one
this one's just my my my name oh my god
there it is well howdy's side profile
this is my side profile everyone this is
my only
the only side profile i like i don't
like this side so we're not going to
show that but
that's my good side well honey down
falls high that is the movie
i mean the directors were both mad men
like they were just pounding coffee like
six
six cups of coffee a day and like we're
just
just grinding it out it took like four
days to do the whole movie which is
not a long time for a movie at all
little hoodie d-pop
i do have a d-pop i do that's uh it's
funny that people actually look that up
i don't know i just don't know how to
like get rid of stuff so i just kind of
give people opportunity to buy it
if they want to my team bobby's name is
lohati for anyone that's wondering i
think
i think it's lottie well how do you
halloween costume
oh good question last year it was i was
harry potter
for halloween me and my sisters were
huge harry potter fans growing up
and i just remade a costume i did when i
was like six years old and
i wanted to redo the pictures that i
took when i was that was that old
you got to be harry potter at least
twice in your life
well how do you lacrosse i am surprised
people actually look this up
i did play lacrosse growing up and um i
was really good at it i was a i was a
good goalie
i also played midfielder i was a good
midfielder i was fast
but i was also crazy behind the net so
that's why i played goalie
howlo hudi how old is luhari i am
i'm 18 years old i am born on may 15
2002.
google mixed it up at one point they
like said i was
18 when i was 17. i also said i was five
seven
when i'm six foot one i went vocal about
it one time i was just like i'm not five
seven and i'm not 18 years old leave me
alone
i'm 17 and i'm 6'1 and then they changed
it but uh i'm 18 now
tall is low i literally answered the
second question my first question i'm
i'm six foot one i keep doing that i did
that before too
how to get little hottie hair
i actually my barber tells me that um
he'll have at least five people a week
ask for my haircut
so this doesn't surprise me that it's on
on here but if you want my hair i do
like a side part kind of a thing
and it's uh it's slicked to the to the
left
and um i i just use some hairspray and
kind of run my hands through it
that's all really how much can little
honey bench
i don't know that's actually a good
question i haven't been in the gym in
two months
maybe i think i've by bench
like 120 right now i can bench
but it's not it's not like too bad
benched like 400.
hello how these touches real and i just
drew them on one day and um
they never went away so i just kind of
let them uh
let them just hang out on my arm it's
one day maybe it might come off
i'm not sure i got a new one not too
long ago i got four bats
and so went from seven to eleven because
they are like
individual little things but yeah i have
a couple tattoos
i'm gonna release like a video on
youtube in like two years
when i have like a whole like a whole
ass
like body full of tats and i'm going to
tell the story on every single one of
them
arlo how do you related
that's a funny one no we are we're not
related but we've been friends for
three years now that's actually so funny
people actually look this up
this is a popular request it's the
second one if you look up arlo huddy art
jaden hostler and chase hudson related i
never thought that'd be something i'd
see
addison related i feel like me and me
and addison would be cousins
if we were related but no we are not
blood related at all
at all last one harlow honey and pain
related oh my god
who looks he's up i'm not related to any
of
these people on um on the search bar i
wish i wish i was related to peyton
peyton's the homie thank you guys so
much for watching i hope you guys
learned something new
about me or took something from this
video and i hope you guys have a great
day
peace out that was a solid toss
oh great that was a good one